[Music]
mitsubishi has given the Lancer a
makeover among the features are a
front-end facelift new rims and an
updated interior it's available in sedan
or Sportback models we tested the sport
back the new front has a wide front
bumper painted in the same color of the
car and a horizontal radiator grille
with chrome
[Music]
what's more there are new headlights
with LED daytime running lights on the
sides this feature however is standard
only in the plus and top equipment
packages
a look at the Lancer Sportback from the
side reveals a flaw that's remained in
the revamped model some team car test a
Manuel shaver says the car still has
blind spots
just like before its facelift the Lancer
had very wide c-pillars a small rear
window and the back seat headrests are
difficult to lower this makes it
difficult for the driver to see what's
behind the car thank goodness a reverse
assist camera is available as an option
yet if you want this driving aid you've
got to choose the plus package or higher
Mitsubishi amanna wa says Mitsubishi has
taken some of the criticism of its
customers too hard because whereas the
previous model at only 270 cubic leaders
of trunk space a new Lancer can fit far
more cargo with 400 in the interior
still has clean line says Amano L with
only a few climate control knobs the
touchscreen does the rest but it's a
shame even the more expensive models
still don't come with a sat-nav golf
place via Honda for the manual says the
car is comfortable but he finds that the
sides of the seats are far too soft all
the advice that's when the car is
cornering you're sort of thrown off
balance the advice is making the sides
of the seats firmer or redesigning the
seating it's an infestation of skeet
the engines are known quantities they
both run on gasoline and produce 86 and
103 kilowatts of power respectively
we're testing the smaller 1.6 liter
model it can take the Lancer Sportback
from zero to one hundred and ten point
seven seconds with a maximum speed of
191 km/h the manufacturer says it uses
5.5 liters of fuel to travel 100
kilometers
[Music]
man whoa says the Lancer Sportback comes
with either a 1.8 liter gasoline engine
with a CVT automatic or what we're
driving a 1.6 liter 5-speed manual
he says the 5-speed is outdated most
cars in this range already have
six-speed transmissions it remains to be
seen whether the facelifted Lancer will
be carried on for another generation
because Mitsubishi is already planning a
midsize sedan for its renault-nissan
Alliance industry analysts say this
model could follow the Lancer perhaps
under a new name as well